Jennifer Aniston has had it with
pregnancy rumors and this time the 47
year old is speaking out
the actress penned an impassioned op-ed
for the Huffington Post on Tuesday about
the rampant rumors putting it bluntly
she wrote quote for the record I am not
pregnant what I am is fed up I'm fed up
with the sport like scrutiny and body
shaming that occurs daily under the
guise of journalism the First Amendment
and celebrity news the essay was
seemingly inspired by the latest round
of pregnancy headlines last month bikini
pics surfaced online that had many
wondering if Jen was in fact with child
speculation was so intense
Jen's rep had to publicly deny she was
expecting Jen explained quote I have
grown tired of being part of this
narrative I resent being made to feel
less than because my body is changing
and or I had a burger for lunch and was
photographed from a weird angle and
therefore deemed one of two things
pregnant or fat all in all seems Jen
just wants to spread a positive message
she said quote we are complete with or
without a mate with or without a child
we get to determine our own happily ever
after for ourselves
I'm very peaceful I feel very peaceful I
literally think that every day like wake
up and feel very lucky feel very
fortunate yeah I got a sweet